alright hello everybody and welcome to
another Raspberry Pi tutorial video in
this video I'm going to be showing you
guys how to make a basic circuit and
also use your GPIO pins on your
Raspberry Pi so just a little bit of
information before we get into it of
what we're going to need and what we're
actually looking at for one on our
actual PI here our GPIO pins or these
pins here there's 26 of them though you
can't actually use every single one of
them what I do suggest is you look up a
basically a diagram online and and see
what the pin which of the pins do what
and so on I believe there's eight total
pins that we can actually use for
input/output and then there are some
pins they honestly I don't know enough
about the PI or computers to know why
they're even there but there are some
things that you're not to plug into like
ever so I don't know why they're even
there but anyway they are there and so
just be really careful with some of the
ones that you plug into so anyway we'll
just go ahead get started that there are
a couple pin or like the whenever you're
looking at a diagram it's assuming they
you're oriented like this and it's the
top right is where the GPIO pins are
located on the board so whenever you see
a diagram that's how it's order and then
the pins go like 1 2 3 4 5 6 and so on
and then the other thing to keep in mind
is the GPIO actual like label of the pin
is a little different than the actual
pins label and there so when you're
programming you need to like by default
it's actually going by the name of the
pin that the pins number but you can
also program in to your you know your
your Python program to say actually
we're going to use in number whatever
but for now what we're going to do is
actually call the pin bytes of you know
program name
so anyway that's the board I'm gonna
move it out of the way now a few other
things that you're in need I did kind of
warn you in a previous video if you
don't have these things you can I guess
still watch the video but you should
definitely get hands-on some is a
breadboard
this is a cheap breadboard and you can
really get a breadboard and like all
kinds of fun stuff on like eBay or
something like that just type in like
breadboard kit and you get just a bunch
of stuff but the next few things that
you're going to need is at least for
this tutorial is an LED light which I
already have I just got a little tiny
LED light and you'll need a proper
resistor for the LED light now um if you
don't if you do know like the forward
the forward voltage and such of your LED
light you can just do the math and
figure out what resistor you mean but
naturally I mean you will need a
resistor because you're pushing 3.3
volts out of your Raspberry Pi it out of
I believe it's the top left for the 3.3
volts you're pushing that out and so if
you plug that directly into this LED
it'll probably shine for like a few
seconds and then it'll just burn out so
you're going to need a proper resistor
for that and for that you'll just have
to do the math because each LED is going
to be a little different so anyway for
example this one's like a little tiny
LED most people have like these mondo
LEDs so this one requires a little bit
more resistance than most most of them
probably require something in like the
under 100 ohms resistance this one this
is a 220 and the little LED flash is
pretty bright
if you don't know though like I didn't
have any documentation on this if you
don't know then what you can do is just
like start really high and then work
your way down until you can start to see
it blinking it'll be like really dim
probably at first and then just go until
it's bright enough so anyway you'll need
that and then finally last thing that
you'll need is a little bit trickier to
find the most of this stuff is male to
female jumper cables it has to be male
to female
because most jumper cables are
male-to-male right like this is the male
end and make this is female because you
can insert into it where all the GPIO
here is is male
so you have to have a female cable so
keep that in mind when you're buying
like a breadboard kit you'll probably
have to buy these separately unless you
go for like an Arduino kit or something
like that or even a Raspberry Pi kit
then it'll have like the male to female
cables but really the whole kit should
cost like $15 like don't pay for
anything more than that so um anyway
we'll need those the resistor LED and
obviously your board and now what we're
going to do is pop over to our Raspberry
Pi and begin getting the things that we
need for the GPIO and then also
programming our our simple program for
GPIO so let's get started
you